what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right so continuing our videos on
the x-men chronology which we need to
get back on track with this remember all
this stuff comes after house of M and
this is kind of cool because this is
basically like the return of pockle of
apocalypse after the events of house of
M now apocalypse has always been a
really really interesting villain he's
one of these characters that nobody ever
really knows how to write and the reason
why is because from the time he was
introduced in over the years especially
in the 90s and like the x-factor stories
with the original team and the x-factor
stories with the second team the
government-sanctioned team apocalypse
was always one of these villains where
it's like if he chose to he could
eradicate the x-men he could just
destroy them in their entirety he's just
that powerful so the question became
what do you do with a villain like that
now in truth all that goes back to
x-factor issue number four or five when
he made his first appearance by Louise
Simonson at Walter Simonson and he
always used horseman and that was kind
of the caveat that Marvel would
introduce but it was always kind of a
skewed I like okay apocalypse sends out
his horsemen the x-men are the x-factor
defeat the you know defeat the horsemen
so why does an apocalypse step in
instead of just leaving apocalypse just
kind of takes off and the way that
Marvel works to basically explain this
was essentially saying but apocalypse
believes in a social darwinism
apocalypse makes efforts to conquer the
world because in his mind he believes
that he's making people in the world
stronger and so if he has horsemen and
if he sends those horsemen out and the
x-men defeat the horsemen the x-men have
proven themselves worthy for the time
and apocalypse just leaves that's kind
of how a Marvel managed to work that
whole thing in in terms of providing an
answer of why apocalypse doesn't just
destroy all the x-men now there have
been times where apocalypse has made
moves and jumped into different schemes
that are outside of determining whether
or not the x-men are worthy and it's for
a specific goal and like it's taken the
power of multiple groups the Avengers
the x-men Fantastic Four x-factor so on
and so forth to like get him to go away
but one thing to bear in mind it's
really as far as I'm aware when it comes
to the character of apocalypse he's
never truly been defeated he's just kind
of been staved off it's kind of been
like okay I don't feel like dealing with
this anymore and then he just leaves but
the cool thing about this is that after
the events of house of M because 98% of
the mutant population lost its powers
apocalypse just woke up and I remember
apocalypse slumbers right like he goes
through like these one or two thousand
years slumbers or he'll just kind of
stay dormant for a while and it's away
from all over the kind of right amount
and then just bring him back you know
five years or ten years down the line
whenever they want him to return but he
basically shows up here with this
massive space
that he's built of course modeled it
after himself alongside a character
named gazer and gazer was just one of
these mutants out there that was
pondering ending his life more or less
and the result was that he was basically
taken by apocalypse and he's gonna be
transformed into a horseman now this is
one thing to keep in mind whenever
apocalypse turns someone into a horseman
he usually doesn't take individuals who
lust for it there are people out there
who want to be a horseman of apocalypse
and he usually rejects them because what
he wants is to basically grab a person
who is deemed to basically be weak
whether they're weak in mind or spirit
or they're weak physically you know it's
the idea that like he can push them and
make them worthy by subjecting them to
genetic modification to brainwashing and
turning them into a horseman so it's
kind of like you know I'm making you
someone worthy and then in turn you'll
go forward and do my bidding but at this
point we switch over to the horseman of
pestilence and of course the whole role
of pestilence is to basically spread
illnesses across the world now depending
on what era were talking about this can
be done in different ways
whenever Apocalypse chooses a person to
become a horseman he usually selects an
individual whose powers will complement
whatever role they're going to be
playing and so historically speaking
when a person became pestilence it was
usually a mutant sometimes a human but
usually a mutant that had the ability to
basically kill things with you know they
had like a deft touch of sorts or the
ability to like spread disease or to
make a person sick or something along
those lines that was the original
pestilence in this instance with the
mutant population being so low to be
quite frank the pickings are slim that's
really all it is and it's kind of cool
because in this instance pestles is
actually going to like various places
around the world and grabbing all these
different diseases that bubonic plague
and smallpox and things like that just
rallying all these illnesses that
humanity would normally have a kind of
cure for and then in turn destroy the
various cures that exist for those
illnesses so it's essentially having all
these illnesses in his possession and no
way to stop it now at this point we jump
back to gazer and again this is the
nature of becoming a horseman for the
most part most horsemen are already like
tried and proven in the sense that like
they've been fours in the fires of
combat or they know how to fight or
whatever the case may be but this goes
all the way back to the original X
Factor story the idea was that when
apocalypse first made the horsemen there
was no real leadership among the
horsemen it was just four horsemen and
so what he did is he had them all fight
each other and whoever won would be the
leader and it turned out to be angel or
I guess arc angel who was the horseman
death who became the leader of the
horsemen the result is that in this
and since and because of apocalypse is
basically in a rush it's let's test
these guys let's see what they're worth
we're gonna put their medal to the test
essentially to see if one of them is
gonna become a horseman and whoever wins
they're the one who will become the
horseman war of course Ozymandias steps
in and takes out one of the other guys
and spares gazer now Ozymandias is of
course the chronicler of apocalypse
the only real role he serves is to
essentially write down the whole life
and times of apocalypse and so the
result is that awesome anteus has really
kind of become the scheming guy now a
lot of that goes into the origin of
Ozymandias which you're welcome to watch
the video down in the description which
will give you the origin on his whole
character suffice it to say he was
unwillingly forced into his position and
the result is that he's really been
working over the millenia to try to find
a way to like destroy apocalypse and
free himself from his imprisonment and
possibly even replace apocalypse and so
that's the whole basis behind his idea
the issue with this is that for
Apocalypse himself he has to find a new
horseman you know he's fine you know the
the third horseman that he's looking for
and so what we end up doing is switching
over to Sun Fire now this picks up out
of an existing story that would there
really was no reason for us to cover it
was basically an idea where Sun fire was
you know had kind of jumped into a
conflict he was double-crossed and he
had his legs cut off by Lady Deathstrike
who was the one-time love interest of
Wolverine turned into a villain having
cyborg modifications the reason why he's
kind of in this infirmary is because of
that because his legs have been removed
but the idea was Sun fire is he's always
been exceedingly proud if not arrogant
now he had a huge empire under his belt
and that's why he was all really
happening that's why I kind of maintain
that mindset but the idea that he's now
bedridden because he lost his legs is a
pretty crushing blow because in his mind
he's kind of like half the person he
used to be but the idea is that
apocalypse showing up on his doorstep
and basically saying hey look I
recognize you lack faith in yourself now
I can't give you the means to return
yourself to who you were before
Sunfire almost leaps at the opportunity
the problem with this is that Sunfire
knows who apocalypse is and when the
devil makes deals those deals always
have caveats and that's what this is
about is really kind of this situation
where Sun fires like yeah you show up
this gift is too good to be true there
has to be something with it but in the
end he ends up going with it he ends up
taking the offer it's provided to him by
apocalypse and so what we end up doing
is jumping back to the Xavier mansion
now one thing I wanted want you guys to
bear in mind this takes place before the
events of deadly Genesis and I'll throw
this under that playlist before that
story so that you guys don't really get
confused in terms of where it's supposed
to reside but the idea is that Xavier
hasn't
the issue with this is that Polaris has
basically gone missing now of course
Lorna Dane the daughter of magneto or at
least you know it was believed she was a
daughter of magneto at this point in
time was a love interest of both Havoc
and Bobby Drake having being the brother
of Cyclops Bobby Drake being Iceman the
issue of this is that while she wasn't
really dating them at the same time
they've dated her at different points in
time and so they both have a romantic
interest towards her now at this moment
havoc was the one who was believed to be
romantically involved with her but
ultimately things kind of went awry and
she just sort of vanished and that was
about it
but the issue is that apocalypse pops up
on the scene and suddenly people began
to panic and the reason why is because
again when apocalypse shows up your head
turns because that's when things are
about to pop off the guy can do all
manner of things he's one of the most
powerful mutants to ever exist and when
the x-men face off against apocalypse is
always preceded by the horsemen and then
the question has to be asked is this the
day of ha caliphs will kill us and by
all rights he should be able to destroy
them the other half of this is that
apocalypse doesn't show up looking for
battle he shows up and says I'm here to
save you all now what you guys are at
right now because of the fact that you
guys are basically at 10% of the
population that you used to have you
guys have proven yourselves worthy now
that's kind of the irony of it because
they had no hand in that it was like a
massive battle went on in the you know
whatever 198 mutants survived to be the
ones who'd be allowed to keep their
powers they had them all stripped away
by the Scarlet Witch but apocalypse
deems them worthy and that's kind of a
thing to bear in mind when is with this
character when it comes to who the who's
worthy and who's not
it's we'll just kind of left to his own
devices its whoever he likes the most it
is cool because when apocalypse shows up
he basically says I am planting the
seeds of like plague in disease and
illness and like 90% of humanity is
going to be destroyed but what I have
here is something that can keep you
protected the other half of this is that
famines suddenly start showing out now
of course famine like you would expect
basically has the ability to force
people into believing that they're
they're basically starving that they're
you know dehydrating you know because
they're exceedingly thirsty an
apocalypse says well I have this this
drink here one sip of this drink will
quench any thirst you have it will
satiate any hunger that you have if you
want it all you have to do is pledge
your loyalty to me people just come
flying at them some of them kind of
stand back and sure they're struggling
just like everybody else and they're
they believe they're starving just like
everybody else but they don't really
give in and those individuals who don't
really give up are the ones who are
experienced with this we're like look
this is the game that apocalypse place
this is how he does this but for the
most part people don't care they're just
kind of like whatever you know this guy
has the ability to satiate whatever
hunger I have I will do whatever it is
he asks me to do if he gives me some
measure of nourishment so again this is
why he kind of shows up as a messiah of
sorts the issue is that in the middle of
all this we're suddenly met by the
arrival of gambit who effectively hands
himself over to Apocalypse Now again we
covered this in terms of like gambit
becoming the horseman death so if you
want to know what happens after this
moment between you know what we're about
to talk about here in a second and like
this point where he shows up that's
covered in that particular comic but it
is kind of intriguing because gambits
always been one of these guys who's kind
of an on-again-off-again an x-man and
you know felt betrayed by the x-men but
he always comes back so there is a lot
of loyalty to the x-men there and in
fact that's something that he says when
he's being turned into a horseman I'm
not doing this because I believe in your
cause I'm doing this because someone
needs to keep you in check but again
there's a lot of scheming and stuff
going on here behind the scenes with
Ozymandias and this is kind of the funny
moment because Ozymandias is talking to
apocalypse and he's basically saying
look you should have just obliterated
them like why not destroy humanity like
why not wipe out humanity in its
entirety they're weak and if the if
they're weak and the weak don't deserve
to live then destroy the weak destroy
humanity and war apocalypse kind of
counters with this and saying you have
no idea what's going on Ozymandias his
initial response is well you've grown
weak over the years and apocalypse slams
his head into a wall and that's what I
love so much about that because he's
like I've had enough of your trash talk
man like and that's that's that's what's
so ironic is apocalypse could just kill
him apocalypse his belief system of
social Darwinism survival of the fittest
only the strongest deserve to survive it
is both a platform by means by which he
makes his case and his own prison will
only the strong deserve to survive and a
person who's strong enough to kill me
must be exceedingly strong if I'm
destroyed by this person then that
person deserves to destroy me I deserve
to die whereas he looks at this
circumstance and it is what we can't
destroy humanity because they have to
prove themselves worthy but life would
be easier if humanity was obliterated
off the face of the earth and all that
was left his mutants but again with this
whole idea of scheming sneaking behind
the scenes all this cloak-and-dagger
stuff
initially Ozymandias tries to strike a
deal with with war simply showing up to
gazer and saying look man I saved your
life when you were gazer so that you
could become a horseman you are now I
told you a debt would be owed I'm asking
you this favor I need you to help me to
join apocalypse and initially gays
doesn't really offer an answer war
doesn't really tell him what direction
he's gonna go in he just kind of
shuffles around a bit now this is
something else I also want you guys to
notice too when it comes to characters
and Marvel comics take like Franklin
Richards for example exceedingly
powerful as powerful as they always are
Marvel always builds in caveats or at
least they try to
in this instance there is a way to
basically shut down the powers of
Apocalypse you have this guy named pulse
who seemingly has the ability to do that
you know pulse has this ability to kind
of take down of how apocalypses powers
even if it's only temporary even if it's
only for a short amount of time the
issue is that a being of that caliber a
being of that power almost seems beyond
pulses ability to basically take down on
his own and so of course you'll play the
role and he'll do whatever it is that he
needs to do but it is kind of cool
because it's like you trying to
benchpress 500 pounds having never
lifted weights before and so ultimately
we basically pick up with the idea that
Sunfire is famine having made his
arrival and you know forcing everybody
to believe they're starving and so on
and so forth he basically been captured
by the x-men and what this did is it
allowed the x-men to hold him in stasis
and then in turn decide how they were
going to revert him back to being
Sunfire because bear in mind when a
person becomes a horseman there are
modifications genetic modifications that
are made to them sometimes they're given
new powers and their old powers are
wiped away sometimes their old powers
are enhanced sometimes they have no
powers and they're given powers but when
it comes to like believing that their
horseman death or their horseman war or
famine or pestilence they're brainwashed
into believing that for the most part it
usually works depending on the character
but Marvel always builds that in is like
a way to bring them back when Wolverine
became a horseman of apocalypse it took
like I think it was Jubilee or Kitty
Pryde I could never remember which one
it was one of the two who basically
showed up and said it look like you have
to come back like you have to be one of
us remember who you are and then he
regained his mind and that was really
about it
but of course Ozymandias shows up
basically sneaks into the x-men mansion
you end up having war who runs through
apocalypse spills the beans about the
traitorous nature of Ozymandias and so
Ozymandias says look I want to take down
apocalypse just as bad as you guys do
our motivations for why we want to take
him down are different but we both want
to take him down he leads them inside
the Sphinx through a secret passage and
when they arrive apocalypse is basically
ready for them all and that's what's so
ironic this moment right here this
moment when like havoc shows up and
rogue shows up should have been the
destruction of these guys apocalypse
should have just been like nope and then
just wipes them all away you know and
just obliterates them in their entirety
which he could but instead he's just
like I am NOT alone
here are those who follow me as well as
my horsemen and it's just kind of like
okay I mean I guess that works but then
you also have in revealing the newest
Horsemen of gambit the horsemen death
and I want to say right now
he looks so amazing as the horseman
death my lovely he's got the whole like
you know like early 2000s goth like I'm
so misunderstood by the world you know
if the whole emo look but initially
rogue tries to bring him back and again
you know the the kind of inner turmoil
that you deal with when it comes to
these various individuals who end up
being turned into horsemen rogue tries
to bring him back by sort of building on
that connection the two of them have
shared over the years of fact that
they've been in love it doesn't really
work not initially anyway Lisa doesn't
seem like it instead he just kind of
continues this campaign to take on these
various x-men now of course this leads
to the destruction of the cure which of
course forces apocalypse to kind of
scrap the plans as they exist now and
modify them a little bit apocalypse says
okay fine look it's time to go we got to
get out of here like like we'll go
modify our plants won't worry about the
x-men later for right now we need to go
focus on bigger things on better things
and so what is up happening is
apocalypse alongside his horseman shows
up at the United Nations and essentially
makes this giant declaration to all of
humanity he but you know he basically
says look here's what's gonna happen
only 10% of the mutant population is
left and so humanity will call its
population by 90% meaning they'll
eradicate 90% of their own population
you guys will be on an even keel but
it's kind of cool because he backed him
into a corner he says right now my
horsemen pestilence has all these
illnesses and diseases that are out
there and will unleash them across the
world either you can sacrifice
90 percent of humanity or I will wipe
out 100 percent of humanity the choice
is yours and you have a week to decide
what you want to come up with now this
is kind of cool because logic would
dictate you would wipe out 90% of
humanity like you you would say okay
fine we gotta wipe out 90% and maintain
the last 10% is utilitarianism the needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
few but when you're dealing with numbers
that are almost that small when there's
there's a 10 percent difference between
the mini and the few is there really a
difference at all
percentages make huge differences when
it comes to like numbers and things like
that so it is kind of funny what do you
look at it from that perspective but the
fact remains here that what is up
happening is we end up switching over to
you know Valerie Cooper meeting up with
x-men and havoc now of course Valerie
Cooper was at one point the liaison
between the government-sanctioned
x-factor team and like the federal
government itself and so she would pass
information to them and
she would keep the government abreast of
what x-factor was doing and they would
usually get their missions from the
federal government and the result was
that once Valerie basically left that
position she kind of went on to other
things but still worked alongside the
government in fact she was originally
part of Project wide-awake which was the
government program to control and
contain the mutant threat when it first
started popping up so she's been around
for quite some time but the idea here is
that what they basically been working on
or like these more advanced versions of
sentinels basically signals it are still
man that are still controlled so they
don't have to worry about like a Days of
Future past event but they are they are
more capable of taking down more
powerful threats it's basically them
just kind of stockpiling weapons and
planning for like bigger and more
dangerous things and so what we end up
doing is switching back over to
apocalypse in a conversation that he's
having with with pestilence only for us
to find out that pestilence is actually
Polaris that when she had gone missing
it's because apocalypse had taken her
and shanghaied her into becoming one of
his horsemen where she fought and she
didn't want to have anything to do with
it ultimately she was pressed gained
into it and she's become a horseman this
entire time and so she's the one kind of
operating behind the scenes now the cool
thing about this is that with apocalypse
you know at the United Nations in New
York what we end up having is like the
arrival of the Avengers and the x-men
these massive superhero teams but the
Avengers aren't really there to like
defeat apocalypse I mean they're there
to beat him if they can but the whole
idea is to try to like take him out take
out his various forces take out his
horsemen which for the most part happens
now this is usually what goes on with
apocalypse in comics these horsemen pop
up and by whatever man or in whatever
means the horsemen are systematically
destroyed and it's a way for Marvel to
just kind of knock over the different
pieces remove two different pieces from
the board so they can wind this story
down and so in this instance apocalypse
basically just kind of retreats he just
sort of says okay come to get while the
getting's good and that's one of the
things about him is usually whenever he
leaves he's always got a back-up plan
to bail out as fast as he can of course
gambits defeated essentially knocked
unconscious Polaris's knocked
unconscious and so they're basically
taken away and so apocalypse retreats to
the core of the ship with the intention
of just sacrificing himself and killing
himself and that's what's so important
about this story is because apocalypse
has never done that before he's come
very very close to dying but apocalypse
usually always escapes sometimes by the
skin of his teeth sometimes because he
just walks away and says enough is
enough but this is one of the first
times if not the first time they
basically sacrificed himself and tried
to die and the reason why is because
what we end up finding out is when
apocalypse
was younger any first encountered
celestial technology he didn't know how
to use it now largely that was all due
to the fact that he was living in
ancient Egypt and so I mean if I went
back there with a TV he wouldn't know
how to use it but he was basically a
technology way beyond his ability to
understand even right now in the Marvel
Universe for the most part with the
exception like Reed Richards and maybe
Tony Stark celestial technology is way
beyond anybody on Earth's ability to
understand it's you know thousands if
not hundreds of thousands of years into
the future in terms of how advanced it
is and what it is that people can do
with it but what apocalypse is given is
basically all the information on how to
access this technology and how to use
this technology so for those of you guys
who are familiar with the cable and
Deadpool's story where we basically get
the the origin where like cable jumps
back in time and he basically fights
apocalypse and then apocalypse merges
with celestial technology and then
becomes uber powerful this takes place
right between that that particular story
this one right here takes place between
that cable and Deadpool story before
that story happens but when apocalypse
is basically you know met with the
arrival of the Celestials they basically
say we'll teach you like we'll give you
all the information you need you know
what Wilson is like well beam it into
your brain and you'll know exactly how
to use all of our technology but there
will be future payments now this is
where things are ambiguous because we're
not told what those future payments are
but because of the fact that this is all
part of x-men reload which again was
Marvel's way of basically getting rid of
all these older characters or shuffling
them around or taking them off the board
or whatever the case may be it was away
from Marvel to essentially remove up
Hakka lips who had just kind of been a
lingering villain for a couple decades
who just floated around from time to
time
you know honestly Marvel didn't really
need to do that it's not like apocalypse
showed up all the time you know he'd
show up whenever so I mean if he never
if we didn't see him again for 20 years
fans would have been like yeah he was
probably just sleeping you know whatever
and they would have just written it off
that way but Marvel decided to kind of
take this story to basically remove him
from the equation and as far as I'm
aware the original intention was to
actually kill him off so that we would
never see him again which of course
didn't happen because he comes back
later on but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
- make sure you guys are the sub button
to become part of the robb cork if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like I also do remember a lot of
you guys really wanted to see the follow
up with that Nimrod story where Nimrod
comes back after the events of a William
Stryker waging war on the New Mutants we
can cover that if you guys are really
interested in seeing that again at this
point is just kind of whatever it is
that people are interested in that takes
place before the endangered-species
event we're kind of
covering all the stuff that people might
find interesting between those things so
anyway guys we're gonna bring this to an
end and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you